you know thank you are you guys doing
Halloween this year you and I I don't
know I think we're gonna go spend
Halloween with our nieces go
trick-or-treating you guys we saw
Suspiria last night I know you're a girl
that's right let me tell you something
it was there's a scene in that movie I
don't want to give out the spoiler the
spoilers but you'll never be the same
it's a it's a dance recital it's a
dancer and you will have never seen a
scene like that on on the screen it's so
cryptic and scary
you'll cringe yeah yeah but go check do
is that one through ten you give it
eight point eight point five in eight
point yeah it's scary yeah I mean it's
not only that it's like hereditary you
have to there's different um acts so you
have to really pay attention I thought
it was about witches is just big it goes
deep it goes deep yeah is it better than
hereditary it's hard to compare the two
but it's the way it's shot is beautiful
and like it takes place in Germany and
you know Cold War era and it's just shot
so beautifully acting is amazing you
know you were like it looks like a cross
between Black Swan and Rosemary's Baby
exactly that yeah and it's exactly that
Tom York does the dude that the music
Tom York is amazing the music is amazing
in it please watch it it's that good
yeah there's a scene in there you will
not be I'm telling you you will not be
the same you'll watch it and you'll look
at Bob like what the hell is going on
this is crazy about what do you give
haunting on Hill House Netflix well are
you on he's done he's on for I mean I
forgot I forgot I thought you finished
it what do you give it so far along the
rail I'm like Luke's kiowa yeah that
that carrot that that's not until five
no look story is for it is
yeah the Hat man yeah hat man yes
number five is bent neck lady yeah I
haven't seen that
that's Nellie's laughing episode a my
team to you know be on my side yeah yeah
I love the series man well you have to
admit though this though the scariest
scene is when the two sisters are in the
car no hold on he's not there yet not
there yet but he give it so far the rain
out of 10 yeah eight point six so
everything's in 8.52 you
well it's purely a purely I was eight
two point five yeah we have houses 48.5
as well Hill House Hill House yeah eight
point six eight point six so you give it
a point about have to because it's ten
hours long I love it
it's great so far I love the story I
like the the dynamic with the family
members I like the history of the house
yeah it's really its heartbreak yeah how
would happen to all of the siblings it's
just a sad story
I like how each episode was thus far is
focusing on close it before continues it
will I think I think I think you I've
maybe very being a survivor - yeah yeah
it's gonna be great so you have
something to look forward to watch I do
I do
yeah I might do that with Ione Halloween
Halloween watch all of them yeah yeah
yeah I can't get her to arm even finish
the we're on episode 10 and we've been
trying to watch the last one for a while
ten oh there's ten so we're done you
didn't know that no I'm just going one
episode yeah one through you go one
through ten yeah four was good before
was very the last one you have a very
last one are you watching it Gilbert
okay why cuz Red Dead okay yeah red did
it you know I'm limiting myself
[Music]